ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui sera plus fort que la miss vous
allez avoir une minute pour répondre aux
plus de questions de culture générale
possible et on fera la même chose avec
les chroniqueurs on va démarrer que les
chroniqueurs d'accord et on va voir qui
va répondre plus de questions une minute
pour les chroniqueurs je rappelle c'est
un test de culture générale
maxim's a le droit de dire je passe les
chroniqueurs bien sûr sellal après
l'autre bon une multi et après ce sera
de clémence attention avec le jaune et
le bleu qu'elle est la troisième des
couleurs primaires beinheim rouge rouge
bonnes réponses citées de membres du
futur jury de the voice the butt marc
lavoine et amel bent très bien quelle iv
novelli cité un membre de jean michel
maire un combat très bon bonne réponse
quelle chaîne se trouve sur le canal 18
de la tnt vous nous taksim gagner ses
news non si julius il y fit des lettres
a b présente sur l'emballage de certains
produits alimentaires isabelle
morini-bosc ma nes et agriculture
biologique bravo qu'est ce qui peut être
de pain de tambours ou de sourcier
géraldine la baguette
vrai ou faux aliens m6 va prochainement
lancer une émission de magie où karine
le marchand va essayer de faire
disparaître les téléspectateurs est bien
vrai mais je vais dire faut combien font
8 x 5 1 40
ouais au calme autour de trois lettres
désignent la mamelle d'une vache
médaille me pique très bonne de quelle
couleur et le jdd personnes qui
manifestent en france en ce moment john
wall réponse alors attention à voir
combien vous avez de bonnes réponses
non si on a beaucoup plus apparemment en
régie tient pas compte et un an mais
sans rigoler ils ont un truc à faire
c'est à hull benhaim ya eu judiciaire 2
3 5 6 7 9 8 9 il ya eu neuf 9 de réponse
à 6 il ya une autre bonne raison ils me
disent non ddd phénomène et benhalima
beria 1 2 3 isabelle 4 5 ayem si c'est
mon septième il dira la ville il me dit
cissé sont persuadés sa demande normale
si ma fille attention on va jouer
maintenant avec clémence clément vous
avez huit bonnes réponses à battre
j'espère que vous allez les défoncer
clémence
attention c'est parti
quel nom donne ton aux habitants de la
nouvelle zélande les calédoniens
non les néo zélandaise rbs qui peut être
de billard de pie ou encore de cheval
vrai ou faux dans danse avec les stars
il ya plus de danse que deux stars oui à
puiser dans quelle cité française est
surnommée la ville rose qui est pour moi
la fille de la soeur de mon père la
fille
la soeur de mon père c'est bouchra non
c'est ma cousine
combien y at-il de gran dans une tonne
1000 1 minute et 1 million deux derniers
livres des frères bogdanov a pour titre
le visage de dieu où nous ne mentons
jamais le visage de dieu de quel pays
est originaire la bossa nova le brésil
oui quel est le prénom d'antoine
griezmann entre louis de quoi ai-je peur
si je suis mise aux phobiques et dont il
me faut vite mis dans une vacherie de la
soupe miso
non c'est de la saleté des microbes
parce que je le vaux mieux derrière un
questeur carter castaner ou à
l'extérieur
c'est à dire ouais franchement voilà
dernier s'est passé une élection il est
plus facile merci on peut le dire c'est
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]